all right people who follow me on
Instagram at David Pakman are probably
aware that over the weekend over the
Memorial Day weekend I was in Montreal
Canada and we're going to talk about
that a little bit let's start with
looking at the two most popular pictures
from my Instagram account over the last
week Pat first we have this still image
which took place while filming here in
the studio and I look absolutely shocked
and perplexed here and I posted it on
Instagram saying what must Pat have said
that made me look this confused and the
speculation was running wild you look
angry I mean you look as if I just
kicked your dog or melted your entire
family I mean that's a bad look today
and you know I guess the lesson to be
learned is when you take live motion
video you can find still images that
look really really funny and odd it
doesn't even look like I'm saying
anything controversial no you look very
calm and for some reason I'm incredibly
agitated
also for my Instagram account David
Pakman here is me drinking not coffee
Pat but a beer a beer in Montreal Canada
and as we know no matter what I post
there's criticisms when I post pictures
of me drinking coffee David you know
coffees not good for you you should
drink tea instead it's not good to drink
coffee then I post the beer and it's out
David's now an alcoholic what happened
to drinking coffee he switched from
coffee to beer you just can't win on
social media is what I'm learning yeah I
mean it's plenty of criticisms there
they could say that you're having the
wrong style or brand of beer as well
sure yeah and they did obviously people
saying what what kind of beer is that it
was a Cronenberg and yeah you know you
can't please everybody and very often
you can't please anybody but that sound
very Canadian - are you immersing
yourself in the culture I you know I
think I did I don't think that I was I
was I neither you have to be really
careful these days I did not participate
in cultural appropriation while on
mitrokhin French Canada but I also
didn't participate in rejection of local
culture either you know I think I struck
the right balance during my trip to
Montreal coming harder and harder to do
this it really is yeah but anyway I'll
talk more on the bonus show about my
trip i'm on instagram at david pakman